les séries on va rentrer dans le top 5
des meilleures blagues de la grosse
rigolade
alors en numéro 5 et bien c'est mon
philippe lellouche qui est numéro 5 avec
son histoire du sinn haber regarde ses
deux copains qui se rencontrent il y en
a un qui dit à l'autre tu vas bien le
dif est extrêmement bien elie dans deux
mois je suis milliardaire je faisais
avant mais pourquoi ben ali parce que
j'ai inventé un procédé révolutionnaire
et là le monde entier est en train de se
l'arracher
c'est à la fois écolo c'est fait c'est
vraiment de l'entreprise 2.0 nous
saluons me dis c'est quoi il dit j'ai
trouvé le moyen de transformer la merde
amber sais je sais que c'est que ces
conneries
la piscine est à 2 km je t'emmène vote
idi ben ouais je veux bien parce arrive
un truc sur cinq hectares on à la police
un truc sublime je rentre sur l'intrigué
bombe à la la la la première machine bon
bah c'est pas dans un premier trio
première transformation là évidemment à
deux kilomètres là bas tu vois c'est la
deuxième transformation
ici elle conditionnement arrive de vente
une motte de beurre jeu sera incroyable
a dit ferri 10 et bombadil goutte comme
je suis pour un bout de pale aboud qui
donne à son pote de crise a quand même
un goût de merde hein ah bah oui
[Rires]
pour l'avoir dit wattao celle-là on peut
la voir mieux fois qu'est ce que vous
soyez je disais mon deuxième spectacle
se plaît au ben oui à cause de cette
blague
et ben voilà elle et elle est magnifique
c'est là mon rêve mon fils tu n'en a
régalé je te fuis au canada alors on va
rentrer dans le top 4 des meilleures
blagues
chantal est ce que tu penses que tu es
dans le top 4 très bien raconté que non
je pense pas bah si pour moi pour moi tt
tutoré puteaux tu l'aurais mérité
franchement tu l'aurais vérité ma chérie
alors on va rentrer dans le top 4 en
numéro 4
c'est michel boujenah c'était une blague
qui a rencontré d'ailleurs pas dans la
grosse rigolade mais dans la grande
d'arcade d'ailleurs c'est ce qui nous a
donné l'idée de créer cette émission
regardez cette boujenah c'est parti
[Musique]
lorsqu'il dit il à ses deux pieds pis on
veut pas vu depuis un certain temps et
il se croiser il fait bon tu vois effet
faire voir que si on fait ce week-end
moi j'étais alcover tient à deauville
ouais témoin tête au casino - comment ça
s'est passé
bon aure voit que de raconter moi pas
alors m après coup argent est mal fait
liffran j'avais moi je prive pas et ça
en car ou est restée aux haras aux usa
les gens mais le soin 8
avant ça m'a dit qu'est ce qui s'est
passé oui qu il conclu à saint baptiste
a gagné 36 fois du froid ouais je savais
et brille tout j'ai mes soins 8 tu vois
de voir où et qui s'est passé oui que
juste après
assez tôt je voyais plus le pit a que ça
fait partie des tous britanniques ont
perdu non voilà faire durer trois heures
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dans une heure et musique raconte
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'elle a fait moi combien
[Applaudissements]
quand il a tout misé sur le web
non il ya un couple est arrivé avec un
crayon au complet il m'a fait un cadeau
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est [ __ ]
de merde moi le type là le spécial de
maintien j'aurais mangé les couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les âges vous jure c'est cette blague
qui dos d'âne
il a donné l'idée de faire la grosse
rigolade enfants dans la elles étaient
quatre les chiffres de l'otan ce que je
propose c'est qu'on se retrouve dans un
instant avec le top 3 des meilleures
blagues de la grosse rigolade
ouais je n'y a pas de système et gagner
bah oui on sait et ce que je propose
c'est que chacun on raconte une petite
juste après pour voilà pour le kit comme
ça en prend le nom là c'est quoi comme
ça allait au oui/non en after en after
d'accord on se met ça l'accord a les
seins alors les cherry et au bar on va
se retrouver dans un instant mais
finalement il ya pas de pub voilà on est
mieux largement pas les cherry on a en
direct lundi depuis new access en
rigoler c'est magnifique parce qu'on
veut faire gagner de l'argent à ses huit
dont ces périodes difficiles et on vient
de me dire no line on n'envoie pas de
pub ça les fous dans la merde bon bah
très bien c'est la seule chaîne dans la
merde
[Rires]
jean-marie je rappelle que l'abus
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
toi c'est que tu as le nez de bouder ces
méchants c'est pas grave ça passe alors
mes ou pas pu lui a remis ça va tu
chéris un peu beauf un public et pas
depuis bien je te raconte une blague et
ils viennent de brandir écouter à ces
maudits
non non vraiment pas de pub ça les fout
vraiment dans la merde donc à quoi sert
il savait qu'il combatte de nuit ouais
peu loin il voit une main il voit une
fille une bombe atomique
ouais elle lui plaît alors lui il va il
traverse toute la boîte et commence un
peu la danse avec elle
et là il s'aperçoit qu'elle pût mais
t'as jamais vu quelqu'un charbon ma
gorge et j'ai pu pour votre parent ainsi
à lui dit les trois chats et des bâches
professionnels des trois quais mois
[Rires]
allez va justement bouder c'est toi le
numéro 3 telus méreau 3 avec de la
blague de la confiture regarder
[Musique]
c'est un petit garçon sa mère à lui dit
va nous acheter de la confiture pénurie
qu'une fois le quartier il y va y rentre
chez l'épicier dit écoute maman et a dit
dans l'ue de la conviction dit ça tombe
bien je ne confiture qui vient d'arriver
des états unis le petit prend la
confiture tchèque et rentrer chez lui
mais sur le chemin je dirais aux états
unis il faut que je bouge alors les
louves le truc il a goûté violet arrive
pas parler la rive c'est sa mère du
joueur sa culture ça s'avère ardue mais
c'est pas possible de moi le pot elle
prend le policier on l'en faire simple
je le fais en sorte que ses trois
bambins le qui les a le père il prend le
bonus est pas possible cette famille
c'est pas possible et par énerver chez
l'épicier
vous m'avez dit écoute je n'étais pas
content vous concert au kg sur le chemin
et ce n'est pas le chemin par ne pas
remis ça lors il croise un mec
excusez moi
le commissariat ce que je vais te manger
un pour l autre ils baissent
[Rires]
thackeray bruder j'espèrais sévère j'ai
dit dès ce soir c'est vrai que là ils
souhaitent tous en confinement j'espère
qu'on vous changer les idées
thiam achiri que j'aime beaucoup daniela
lumbroso qui nous envoyait un petit
tweet regarder qui viennent nous dire ça
fait tellement bien en ce moment cette
émission ben merci daniel à en trouver
de gros bisous à tous voilà si je
t'embrasse fort daniela mais c'est vrai
qu'on est plein à se dire voilà ce soir
ça nous fait du bien de rire ensemble a
pour l'instant je vous dire j'ai oublié
toutes les races ras de la deux du
groupe a du coup un seul camion sacré en
tout cas d'être avec nous et vous avez
vu un la chaîne s'est vite c'est pour ça
qu'on les aime aussi il reçu ce mail de
la pub donc bravo paul
rebrab et parce que c'est un état
d'esprit c'est fait pour ça qu on va
rentrer dans le top 2 des blagues et
liver cyril offert une petite abaziou
philippe non non non moi je voulais pas
faire je parais dans un truc tout bête
mais ce que tout le monde sait en ce
moment mais je crois que c'est bien de
le faire
est ce que cette soirée on pourrait pas
la dédier à tout le personnel soignant
106 oui mais c'est vrai qu'ils font un
travail formidable mais il redoute sont
là oui mon chéri ouais bah oui on a put
enfin cela permet donc on applaudit
comme deco mais y'avait personne mais
c'est pas grave je vois les données
essentielles de la télé est-ce qu'on
peut pas applaudir qu'il semble craindre
à vos besoins les chalets avant avold et
moi j'ai envie de faire une dar k parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a un plateau
magnifique ce soir mènera à et philippe
lellouche avec booder avec chantal
ladesou avec liane foly avec du jean
marie bigard et et lola et c'est vrai
qu'il ya plein de gens et qu'ils y sont
on est dans le top de la ce soir et ya
plein de gens qui me disent vous jure
s'te plaît syrie le parquet pas de
l'antenne reste encore un peu quelques
récits aux paisibles et les cherry est
ce que vous voulez faire une petite
blague encore parce qu'on apprend avant
courant dans le top 2 bien entendu est
ce que chantal quant à une petit nam
non sans talent ecoutez jean marie josée
son mari jean mario n'at il pas dit non
mais c'est le mec il veut voir un choix
scientifiques en afrique et le gagne
écoute tu veux pas regretter d'être venu
de vin chaud mène la chasse aux
choristes avec bon et dur et si tu sais
que les oreilles nous on a besoin de les
capturer vivants bien sûr puisque ont
fait des expériences avec eux a dit ok
dit alors on fait quoi va il dit voilà
pour aller à la chasse aubry et le
capturer vivant
il faudra besoin de trois trucs on a
besoin d'un pitbull est très très
méchant on a besoin d'un fusil et d'une
paire de menottes dieu qu'est il arrive
à gérer un arbre et le mec qui lui dit
tu vois dans cet arbre hier au rire
alors aidez-moi je vais monter dans
l'arbre 1
je vais sur coup et la branche ou
elghorri le gorille va tomber par terre
à ce moment la tarière besoin de dire
aux chiens le pitbull et va forcer
dessus et va lui mordent les couilles up
mais à ce moment là je corrige ver
bouilhou y tenons les parties et toi tu
arrives etc actu lui met les menottes à
lever qui dit ouest et astucieux et 10e
et le fusil il sert à quoi le dit alors
le fusil si c'est moi qui sommes de là
tu prends le fusil tutu le chien mots
jean marie c'était arrivé en deuxième
position
jean marie bigard avec ça at on a eu
tellement jean-marie on a eu du mal
voilà ils ont regardé c'est parti c'est
le patron c'est jean marie billa
[Musique]
c'est un métier je mets là pardon faire
un peu d'ombré mais j'adore c'est un
routier kassaï sur le short sur le coup
il voit un petit nain rouge en plein
milieu de la route
il a aidé mais c'est vite dit qu'ici
vous arrive à dinard aussi dit chez ma
voiture qui a glissé dans le fossé
je sais plus quoi faire jour mariage de
mon beau frère je peux pas être d'un
mondial
j'ai un treuil à l'arrière il n'y a pas
de souci garrigues le camion l'accroché
de voitures du team à un rouge rend la
voiture sort du fossé et l'occident lui
dit êtes formidables rechange et je sais
pas quoi faire pour vous remercier
j'avais été tellement chantiers routiers
ni sa est sur la route on s'entraide
c'est tout non mais dis je peux pas vous
laisser partir comme ça si vous voulez
par exemple j'aurais pu vous sucer la
[ __ ]
je ne savais que j'allais bande de gaza
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voyez-vous le routier le routier dit non
mais dis ça va pas non j'ai dit d'où
sortait 10e ils laissent pas le temps
aux routiers de réfléchir le routier
contre le camion lui déboutonne très
vite la braguette
telle est la trame la mitrailleuse
soutient financièrement dans serial ata
le widget qui croient qu'il ya bien un
rouge remontent dans son camion
itri il n ya guère 5 kilomètres plus
loin un petit nom du premier lot
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dix ans la vie tu dis qu'est ce qui vous
arrive à ba exigeait ma voiture qui
démarre plus chez à l'enterrement de ma
long mais un show pas loupé deux
cérémonies c'est dans une heure je n'ai
rien d'arabe
mes chers collègues il ouvre le capot
ben oui c'est la courroie qui est ptc
pour ça l'alternateur charges s'est dit
j'ai toujours un bout de ficelle
il m'avait dit c'est le tas qu'il les
tâches dix essais pour voir didier
guérin redémarre referme le cas pour le
chien jaune a dit je sais pas comment
vous remercier
cette étiquette montchamp tio tio ça ça
va je viens de voir un pote à vous la
formidable c'est bon pour moi c'est
celle est nickel a dit nan nan mais je
me permets d'insister je présente pas si
vous aviez voulu maculé c'est un peu non
hélas le petit nain jaune et lui laisse
pas le temps de réfléchir aux routiers
le plaque contre le camion il se
retourne très vite mais ce sont vos
revenus
et regarde autour de lui a dit souvent
la caméra cachée c'est quoi ce bordel
[Rires]
faisait au début personne remonte dans
son camion sur 5 km plus loin et quoi
soit sorti un petit nain bleu plein
milieu là où tu rêvais savez ce niveau
qu'est ce que tu veux toi tu aimes sucer
du lecoeuche [ __ ] gendarmerie
[Applaudissements]
c'est la nation qui est exceptionnel
c'est l'actionnaire allait elle est
bannie on a vu laurent baffie alors
laurent baffie je vous dis comme il ya
il a créé l'émission un peu avec moi
donnions la paille et du classement et
on fera une spéciale l'holographie toute
la semaine prochaine y aura des blagues
de laurent baffie dans ma quotidienne
voilà lolo que j'embrasse très très fort
merci lolo qu'on aime mon jean marie thé
est écrit que ça tu tu nous régale mon
chéri et les chéris je vous le dis
l'année prochaine la grosse rigolade fin
la saison prochaine va revenir très très
très très très souvent donc j'espère que
vous serez avec moi bien entendu parce
que je vous le dis je peux compter sur
moi et c'est grâce à vous notre si belle
avec lola avec plaisir et tout cela tout
ce que tout ce qui est de vous dire
c'est grâce à vous le succès de cette
émission est ce que c'est vous qui
faites les missions et je voulais vous
remercier ce soir parce que les lettres
de noblesse marcel se marier mois on
s'aime on sait tout jouer mais je n'ai
jamais lâché son mari lui non plus il
sait très bien mais jamais merci mais
chercher les amours jeu et on était
obligé de mettre numéro 1 celui qui nous
a donné l'idée de faire la grosse
rigolade puisque c'est michel blier on
était dans la grande barca est un moment
on a fini les missions et j'ai dit à mes
équipes est catholique et producteur
d'émissions s'est dit mais il faut faire
une émission qu avec des blagues et
cette blague alors en plus c'est le bac
que tout le monde qui sait la blague du
perroquet qu'on a tous déjà la grosse
rigolade c'est la numéro une des blagues
sur les perroquets il y en a plein c'est
le numéro un ce soir c'est michel
boujenah regarder ses portes
alors c'est ainsi une femme c'est son
anniversaire elle veut absolument un
perroquet elle fait tout les percuter du
monde de paris de la banlieue de tout
être pas de perroquets elle est très
très triste elle veut s'acheter un
perroquet c'est très important pour elle
tout est finalement rentré chez elle
passe devant un bibi horrible un vieux
perruquier qui vend des perroquets elles
diminueront ce jour et moi je t'avouerai
question à l'inversé très important pour
moi il fait j'ai pas de perroquets il
fait mais le perroquet que je vois
derrière vous là au fond là qui a une
drôle de tête chalon madame pas celui-là
pas celui-là je peux pas vous vend super
ok c'est impossible
elle lui dit mais pourrait ici parce que
madame ce perroquet très spécial il va
vous gênez il va vous poser des problème
croyez moi il va vous pose des problèmes
mv je m'en fous je mens vous - les verts
je stockais il dit écoutez je vous
préviens super ok il a été élevé dans un
bordel alors il a un langage assez vert
je m'en fous je m'en fous je vois un
perroquet elles rentrent chez elles même
pas vos questions ce qu'on perçoit elle
se change pour elle à faire la fête avec
des copies et à peine elle sort elle et
non près de la porte me perreault qui
fait et salle d'eau tu vas faire la fête
tu vas te faire trancher elle est un peu
vexé mais sans poils contente elle à son
père auquel sans valve revient à 4
heures du matin puis life et ce alors
comment ça s'est passé
tu t'es fait déglinguer bompard convient
mais sans fouille se couche le lendemain
tu es tellement bourberain petit
déjeuner l'arrivée à la butte
elle a bien dormi
dans la journée je me le fais donc je
vous la fais voir a connu son père
obtient des combats y aller très loin
non non non non je peux passer trop à la
maison oui alors elle va elle rentre le
soir tu marches une drôle de manière
tu faire mal plus alors le percuter mais
bonjour monsieur le percuter il a quand
même raison n'oubliez pas que c'est une
solution une recette pour qu'ils se
calment effet cyril vayssié le côté j'ai
une idée je sais pas ça va marcher
je suis pas là cette bombe de peinture
c'est une bombe à perroquet alors c'est
la peinture noire d'equidia mon mal
élevés vous rentrez vous le payez en
noir elle rentre à la maison il arrive
[Musique]
[Rires]
enfin ça s'est passé
elle prend la bombe de peinture noire
[Musique]
là il dit plus rien elle sort le soir
elle revient quatre heures du matin il
dit rien le matin il dit rien l'après
midi il dit rien au bout de toujours
elle regarda faire leur espèce de petit
con à te connais tu la fermes ta gueule
1 et là cela fait quand je suis en ce
moment soit pas oublié
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas trop
[Musique]